existen cuatro diferentes tipos de
tejido animal que están hechos de
células eucariotas tejido epitelial
tejido conectivo tejido muscular y
tejido nervioso aunque en este vídeo nos
enfocaremos en el tejido epitelial y en
el tejido conectivo primero podemos
considerar al tejido epitelial como un
revestimiento tanto interno como externo
por ejemplo el tejido epitelial forman
la capa externa de la piel también la
capa externa de los órganos
este tejido reviste la luz o espacio
interior de los órganos y también
reviste la parte interna de las
cavidades del organismo
el tejido epitelial también forma las
glándulas eso incluye las glándulas
exocrinas y endocrinas sólo para
recordar las glándulas exocrinas liberan
sus sustancias directamente en el órgano
objetivo mientras que normalmente las
glándulas endocrinas liberan sus
hormonas en el torrente sanguíneo es
decir que no las libera en el órgano
objetivo directamente el tejido
epitelial viene en dos formas puede ser
simple lo que significa que sólo tiene
una capa de grosor o puede ser
estratificado lo que significa que tiene
dos o más capas donde esperamos ver
tejido epitelial simple y tejido
epitelial estratificado bueno
encontramos tejido epitelial simple en
aquellos lugares donde las sustancias
necesitan difundirse desde dos lugares
distintos por ejemplo
alvéolos en los pulmones están
revestidos de epitelio simple porque el
dióxido de carbono y el oxígeno
necesitan difundirse desde los alveolos
a la sangre y viceversa y por supuesto
que eso debería ser bastante difícil si
tenemos una capa gruesa de células por
otra parte esperamos encontrar tejido
epitelial estratificado en aquellos
lugares que necesitan resistir un estrés
químico o mecánico
por ejemplo el esófago está recubierto
con epitelio estratificado esto debido a
que pasa por el comida que puede ser
cortante o tal vez caliente y por ello
necesitamos una capa gruesa de células
para proteger el tejido que recubre el
esófago por lo tanto el tejido epitelial
estratificado actúa como una capa de
protección observemos una sección de
epitelio simple
las células epiteliales están unidas a
algo que se le conoce como membrana
basal la membrana basal no está formada
de células está hecha de distintos tipos
de fibras por ejemplo una fibra que
podemos encontrar en la membrana basal
es el colágeno la membrana basal es semi
permeable a ciertas sustancias y esto es
muy importante ya que el tejido
epitelial es a vascular
eso significa que las células
epiteliales no tienen vasos sanguíneos
lo que nos hace preguntarnos cómo es que
obtienen nutrientes bueno obtienen
nutrientes del tejido subyacente los
nutrientes se difundirán del tejido
subyacente por la membrana basal hasta
llegar a las células epiteliales y así
es como el tejido epitelial obtiene
nutrientes ahora repasemos algunos
lugares donde esperamos encontrar
células epiteliales ya hemos mencionado
la capa externa de la piel el tejido que
reviste la boca el esófago y el tracto
gastrointestinal por supuesto esta no es
una lista exhaustiva pero también está
el tejido que reviste los túbulos de los
riñones y el que reviste los vasos
sanguíneos y los linfáticos
de hecho el tejido que reviste los vasos
sanguíneos y linfáticos recibe un nombre
especial se le conoce como endotelio
bien ahora hablemos del tejido conectivo
por lo regular el tejido conectivo
sostiene tejidos conecta tejidos y
separa diferentes tipos de tejidos
aunque existen distintos tipos de tejido
conectivo que no necesariamente entran
en estas categorías cuáles son algunos
ejemplos de tejido conectivo huesos
cartílagos sangre linfa tejido adiposo
que es la grasa las membranas que cubren
el cerebro y la médula espinal y otros
tipos de tejidos ahora bien como se ve
el tejido conectivo cuáles son las
características del tejido conectivo
básicamente tenemos tres componentes
tiene células tiene lo que se conoce
como sustancia fundamental y después
tenemos fibras en conjunto la sustancia
fundamental y las fibras forman la
matriz extracelular así que veamos cómo
se vea
aquí tenemos la sustancia fundamental
que es un tipo de fluido viscoso después
intercaladas a la sustancia fundamental
tenemos las fibras y también tenemos
células y estas células forman la matriz
extracelular vamos a observar con más
detalle el tejido conectivo de lo
primero que vamos a hablar es del tejido
conectivo laxo o ha de hablar que es
este tejido de aquí el tejido laxo es un
tipo de tejido conectivo muy común une
diferentes tipos de tejidos y probé
flexibilidad y amortiguación
podemos ver la estructura claramente en
esta imagen podemos ver las células que
son estos pequeños puntos podemos ver
las fibras por aquí y por acá y están
entre las células y después la sustancia
fundamental este tipo de fondo rosado
que es un líquido viscoso que observarás
después tenemos el tejido adiposo el
tejido adiposo es esencialmente la grasa
y proporciona al cuerpo amortiguación
almacena energía y este es una excepción
a la regla ya que no tiene fibras como
los otros tejidos conectivos después
tenemos lo que se conoce como el tejido
conectivo denso o fibroso el tejido con
el tipo del sol es muy fuerte
provee soporte y amortiguación para
órganos y huesos se encuentra en dermis
que es una capa media de la piel en
tendones y ligamentos aquí hay más tipos
del tejido conectivo tenemos a la sangre
la sangre también es una excepción como
el tejido adiposo ya que no contiene
fibras y la matriz extracelular de la
sangre es el plasma puedes ver la matriz
extracelular como este líquido
amarillento en donde las células
sanguíneas están suspendidas después
tenemos el tejido óseo el tejido de los
huesos y a estas células del tejido óseo
se les conoce como este ositos es decir
estas células cafés que forman un patrón
y la matriz extracelular en el tejido
óseo es lo que se conoce como un mineral
del hueso o hidroxiapatita que
básicamente son las fibras de colágeno
con distintos minerales como fosfatos
magnesio calcio etcétera por último
tenemos cartílago ya lino las células en
el cartílago ya lino son los condrocitos
puedes verlos por aquí tenemos un montón
de estas células
se encuentran en las superficies de las
articulaciones aquí tenemos ejemplos de
los distintos tipos de tejido conectivo
y muchos de ellos proveen forma u otro
tipo de soporte para los tejidos y
órganos